herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen faz
einspruch podcast spezial dem podcast
der faz zu politik recht und justiz das
thema unserer heutigen sonderfolge ist
krieg verschuldung zeitenwende was wird
aus dem grundgesetz mein name ist
reinhard müller ich bin verantwortliche
redakteur für faz anspruch zeitgeschehen
und staat und recht und mir gegenüber
hier in frankfurt sitzt wiederum stephan
klenner hallo liebe hörer ich bin
redakteur bei faz einspruch und nachdem
der ukraine krieg nun leider schon über
fünf wochen in gang ist werden mehr und
mehr die auswirkungen für die deutsche
verfassung sichtbar es wird über
grundgesetzänderungen diskutiert dabei
ist natürlich nicht jede idee neu aber
die ereignisse in der ukraine führen
schon dazu dass manche frage eine
besondere aktualität erhält wir wollen
uns heute damit beschäftigen hinzu kommt
noch dass die ampel koalition auch
unabhängig vom krieg einige
grundgesetzänderungen plant und herr
müller sie sprechen dazu heute mit
bundesjustizminister marco buschmann ja
ich werde ein buschmann zur aktuellen
krisenlage befragen hier eine multiple
ist und auch über gesellschaftlichen
wandel natürlich auch corona dass krieg
sondervermögen sprechen und mit einem
ausblick auf europa in den nach ihrem
gespräch mit herrn buschmann werden wir
dann über das thema wehrpflicht sprechen
das wird ja auch seitdem ukraine krieg
wieder diskutiert ob die wehrpflicht in
deutschland wieder gelten sollte und
dazu hatten wir von herrn klenner von
ihnen einen artikel der natürlich auch
von den abonnenten anspruch zumindest
wahrgenommen wurde aber auch in der
ganzen faz zu lesen war ja vielleicht
ist das sogar der zeitpunkt wo ich noch
mal darauf hinweisen sollte das ja auch
faz einspruch nicht nur ein podcast ist
sondern auch ein magazin ein online
magazin
man kann dort alle artikel zu
rechtsthemen aus der faz lesen aber auch
spannende exklusiv texte von
hochkarätigen gast autoren
das ganze kostet 4 euro 90 im monat für
alle die unter 35 sind für die älteren
dann 14 euro 90 und wer möchte kann das
ganze auch vier wochen kostenlos testen
dazu gibt es einen link und zwar
www.faz.net
schrägstrich einspruch testen dort kann
man das dann einfach mal ausprobieren
und mit dem anspruch aber unterstützen
sie natürlich auch den podcast obwohl er
gar nicht bedürftig ist besitzt mit dem
thema wehrpflicht auf diesen komplex
gekommen herr klenner und wir sind ja
auch sonst an anderer stelle noch mit
der bundeswehr und sondervermögen
beschäftigt ich hatte das schon im
gespräch mit herrn buschmann angedeutet
wo noch ja genau also wir haben das mal
zum anlass genommen uns insgesamt
anzugucken was ist eigentlich ein
sondervermögen ein sondervermögen das
sind ja kreditermächtigung für bestimmte
projekte und aktuell plant eben die
bundesregierung das speziell für die
bundeswehr sogar nochmal in die
verfassung zu schreiben das ist
ungewöhnlich dass es bei anderen
sondervermögen nicht der fall es gibt ja
auch das sondervermögen zum klimaschutz
da wurde der weg eines
nachtragshaushalts gewählt und das eben
da die schuldenbremse dann nicht
eingehalten wird wird damit begründet
dass es eine folge der korona pandemie
sei und deswegen haben sie noch mit
herrn pose gesprochen roberto sieg
präsident des hessischen
staatsgerichtshofs ja genau wo man pose
ist präsident des hessischen
staatsgerichtshofs und hat sich in
dieser funktion damit beschäftigt dass
es in hessen ein ähnliches gesetz gab wo
auch bestimmte maßnahmen mit der korona
pandemie begründet wurden das ganze als
sondervermögen ausgestaltet wurde und
dieses gesetz wurde für unvereinbar mit
der hessischen landesverfassung erklärt
und ich werde herrn buseck dann fragen
ob man da vielleicht rückschlüsse auch
auf die bundesebene ziehen kann ja sie
sprechen zum ende der sendung dennoch
mit udo di fabio herr müller ehemaliger
bundesverfassungsrichter oder ein großer
freund der frau dazu auf ihr geschrieben
hat und da wird es unter anderem auch um
die frage gehen haben wir eine krise der
freiheit selbstbehauptung der freiheit
aber eben auch um grundgesetzänderung
sind sie wirklich nötig oder müssen wir
vielleicht uns auch gedanken machen ob
nicht weniger mehr wäre eine ganze
sendung zu unserer verfassung zum
grundgesetz in der aktuellen lage das
wird eine tolle sendung und wir starten
jetzt mit ihrem gespräch mit herrn
buschmann
[Musik]
herr minister buschmann wir leben in
einer pandemie wir haben einen krieg vor
der tür und sind von einem klimawandel
bedroht leben wir in einer art
permanentem ausnahmezustand
also dieses gefühl kann man natürlich
bekommen trotzdem wenn ich so ein
bisschen in sorge wegen des begriffs des
ausnahmezustandes natürlich bestimmte
aspekte sind so außergewöhnlich dass man
auch zu ungewöhnlichen maßnahmen greifen
muss nur wenn man unter juristen spricht
hat der ausnahmezustand ja immer etwas
von
einer art entbindung rechtliche
grenzen auch für staatliche macht und da
ist es natürlich unsere aufgabe
auch diese herausforderung im rahmen des
verhältnismäßigkeitsprinzip zu
bewältigen das sehe ich jedenfalls als
die aufgabe des bundes justizminister
anderen und die aufgabe der gesamten
regierung ist natürlich diese mehreren
krisen gleichzeitig zu bewältigen aber
ist das grundgesetz ist unsere
grundordnung dem gewappnet davon bin ich
fest überzeugt dann schauen sie die
grundidee des grundgesetzes ist ja die
die würde und die freiheit des menschen
das klingt zunächst sehr abstrakt und
pathetisch aber die bedingungen der
freiheit haben ja
problemlösung beispielsweise in der
pandemie ermöglicht die es woanders
nicht gab schauen sie sich an wir haben
als liberale demokratien als erstes
einen hoch effektiven impfstoff
entwickelt mittlerweile haben wir sogar
eine vielzahl an impfstoffen entwickelt
die aus wissenschaftlicher perspektive
auch das darf man so sagen die besseren
sind im vergleich zu den impfstoffen die
beispielsweise in autokratien wie
russland oder china entwickelt worden
sind wir haben mittlerweile auch einen
umgang beispielsweise mit dem virus
gefunden dass sich der sich radikal
unterscheidet etwa mit dem was wir aus
china hören und
obwohl das alles natürlich noch eine
große herausforderung ist glaube ich ist
der umgang dem wir damit gefunden haben
im ergebnis ein
erfolgreicherer unter humanere und das
alles ist gelungen unter der ordnung des
grundgesetzes und nicht gegen die
ordnung des grundgesetzes
das heißt das grundgesetz hat sozusagen
den nährboden
vorgesehen hat ihn bereitgestellt und
freiheitlich lösungen zu entwickeln aber
das grundgesetz hat ja auch bestimmte
vorschriften hat grenzen hat
beschränkungen zum beispiel etwa die
schuldenbremse die bestimmte vorgaben
macht was auch mit blick auf künftige
generationen
eben an schulden an krediten aufgenommen
werden kann sie wurde er früher oft
gebrochen dann erneuert und jetzt hat
man aber auch den eindruck sie ist
irgendwie nicht mehr so richtig in kraft
oder in dem möchte ich hingegen treten
weil die schuldenbremse ist ja wenn sie
so wollen keinen kein blindes instrument
sondern sehr intelligent die
schuldenbremse sagt im grundsatz müssen
wir eben die generationengerechtigkeit
im blick halten wir können nicht jedes
problem der gegenwart mit schulden
sprich also auf kosten künftiger
generationen lösen auf der anderen seite
kennt die schuldenbremse natürlich schon
das phänomen dass es krasse ausnahme
situation geben kann diese ausnahme
situation beschreibt die schuldenbremse
auch und insofern ist sie ein
gutes instrument das aber auch die
notwendige flexibilität für eben diese
ausnahme situation enthält und insofern
verstehe ich diese kritik nicht so
richtig wenn man sie ernst nimmt nach
ihrem wortlaut in wahrheit steckt hinter
dem wortlaut aber ein anderer geist
nämlich der wunsch vieler die in der
politik tätig sind eben doch wieder
unbegrenzt und ohne rechtfertigungsdruck
auf das instrument schulden
zurückgreifen zu können das halte ich
einfach für politisch falsch rechtlich
falsch ist es ohnehin weil die
schuldenbremse geltendes
verfassungsrecht ist aber ist der weg
zum beispiel über ein sondervermögen da
nicht auch eine art taschenspielertrick
das würde ich weit von mir weisen das
ist wäre ja erstmal eine lex spezialist
im grundgesetz und das bedeutet ja dass
man sich einer sehr aufwändigen prozedur
stellen muss denn das grundgesetz kann
ja nur mit zwei dritteln im bundestag
und im bundesrat geändert werden es ist
hoch transparent und es führt natürlich
zu einer sehr strenge zweckbindung
der mittel die durch ein solches
grundgesetzlich abgesicherte
sondervermögen
bereitgestellt werden denn sie sprechen
ja das sondervermögen zugunsten der
bundeswehr an das ist ja nicht einfach
ein großer topf geld sondern seien
zweckgebundene sondervermögen das
fehlende investitionen der vergangenheit
nach holt damit wir in der welt wie sie
sich eben jetzt darstellt die eben eine
welt ist in der
armee
wieder eine rolle spielen weil wir halt
feststellen dass es nach wie vor den
aggressiven geist gibt dem wir trat
traurigerweise in der ukraine durch den
überfall ostern erleben können das
müssen wir nachholen und dafür wege zu
finden die transparent sind die
nachvollziehbar sind die aber auch
sicherstellen dass dieses geld wirklich
für diesen wichtigen zweck eingesetzt
werden
das ist eigentlich eine kugel lösung nun
ist es klar es ist kein
verfassungsverstoß wenn man die
verfassung selbst ändert mit der
erforderlichen mehrheit aber könnte man
nicht auch versuchen zumindest das unter
die ausnahmen zu subsumieren es gibt nur
naturkatastrophen es gibt vielleicht
dinge wie den krieg dem man auch von
deutschland aus nicht im griff haben
kann die ähnlich sind und ist da nicht
sozusagen das bemühen zu vermissen dass
man versucht sich im rahmen der regeln
zu halten bevor man jetzt sozusagen
weitere ausnahmen die verfassung einfügt
das ist natürlich mit einem risiko
verbunden
die schuldenbremse sagte ich ja vorhin
kennt ausnahmen aber kind vor allen
dingen einen klaren grundsatz strenge
vorgaben und wenn man natürlich jetzt
versucht im wege der auslegung
die dinge sehr stark zu denen auch den
wortlaut zu denen geht man natürlich das
risiko ein dass die schuldenbremse an
die rag tief kraft einbüßt wenn man hier
einen fall hat
wo man sehr lange darüber streiten
könnte ob sich das subsumieren lässt
denn machen wir uns nichts vor dieser
große
investitionsstau ist ja etwas was die
politik und der staat in die hand hatte
und bei den ausnahmeregelungen der
schuldenbremse sagt der wortlaut ja
schon dass es sich um ereignisse handelt
die die politik nicht unbedingt in der
hand hat das kann man sicherlich für den
überfall russlands auf die ukraine
bejahen aber für die frage ob die
politik nicht selber zu so einem
investitionsstau beigetragen hat kann
man mit guten gründen sagen das waren
einfach politische entscheidungen die
sich im nachhinein als falsch
herausgestellt haben und deshalb bin ich
dafür eine klare saubere lösung zu
machen ich habe viel verständnis für all
diejenigen die sagen man sollte im
grundgesetz nicht zuviel punktuell
regeln da habe ich große sympathie für
nur hier geht es ja schon um ein
ausmaß das keine kleinigkeit ist wir
reden über 100 milliarden wir reden über
einen investitionsstau der sich über
vielleicht sogar mehrere jahrzehnte
angesammelt hat und es geht um eine
weltpolitische ausnahmesituation und
wenn es um ein solches ausmaß geht ist
die regelung ist ebene grundgesetz nicht
per se unangemessen und wie wollen sie
die zweckbindung sicherstellen es gab ja
auch schon beim sondervermögen teilweise
auch in den ländern zu corona oder
denkbar sind auch beim klimaschutz
natürlich die tendenz da alles mögliche
einzupacken von fahrradständern bis zur
krabbenpulen maschine die irgendwie im
weiteren sind vielleicht doch mit der
pandemie zu tun haben aber im endeffekt
zeigen dass man sozusagen ein
sondervermögen nimmt um alle möglichen
gelüste zu befriedigen das ist ja auch
denkbar bei einem thema wie sicherheit
und verteidigung
stichwort alles ist sicherheit alles
kann darunter subsummiert werden
ja das wäre zu weit und natürlich darf
man sich einerseits nicht so eng
einbinden das irgendwann gar keine
investitionsentscheidung mehr getroffen
werden können aber es muss schon
klargestellt sein das ist jedenfalls
meine feste überzeugung ist auch die
überzeugung des finanzministers das klar
sein muss dass dieses geld erstens für
die bundeswehr alleine ist und dass es
darum geht
ausstattungs mängel zu beseitigen und
wer fähigkeit zu erhöhen also es geht
nicht um image kampagnen und so weiter
sondern es geht darum die die wehr
fähigkeit der bundeswehr zu erhöhen die
einsatzfähigkeit der bundeswehr zu
erhöhen das wäre
der der zweck den wir anstreben
aber ich will das gar nicht
foto rita tief festlegen wir werden da
auch ja mit der opposition sprechen
müssen denn zwei drittel hat die ampel
ja nicht alleine und die opposition
hätte ja eine wichtige aufgabe der
demokratie wir haben das ja selber über
jahre wahrgenommen und auch die werden
sicherlich
das große anliegen haben dass diese
zweckbindung so ausgestaltet ist dass es
eben nicht möglich ist alles möglich
darunter zu subsumieren wie gesagt das
ist unser interesse ich nehme auch an es
wird das interesse der opposition sein
und dann werden wir der formulierung
finden die das sicherstelle und sie
werden eine eigene mehrheit zustande
bringen ja was heißt eine eigene mehr
also doch ein solcher angebote für sei
nicht der reservebank
ach so ja das ist herr merz macht da ja
in diesem zusammenhang mit diesem
wichtigen thema so ja wie soll ich sagen
also ein bisschen ein taktisches manöver
das er sagt einen teil seiner leute
stimmen dann zu und ein anderer teil
nicht um auszutesten ob auch wirklich
alle abgeordneten der ampel dem
zustimmen das ist ein manöver das will
ich jetzt gar nicht bewerten das
beurteilt sich von selber aber ich gehe
natürlich davon aus dass wir da eine
breite mehrheit haben und dass auch die
abgeordneten der ampel fraktionen wenn
ein kluger vorschlag auf dem tisch liegt
das unterstützen werden weil der
problemdruck ist die objektiv da ist
kann ja niemand von der hand weisen dass
in den letzten
legislaturperioden die bundeswehr
kaputtgespart worden ist die zuständigen
verteidigungsminister nicht den
entsprechenden politischen druck
aufbauen konnten damit das thema
angemessen auch von den jeweiligen
finanzministern behandelt wurde die
weltlage war auch eine andere das muss
man da zu sagen und jetzt müssen wir
einfach handeln und die notwendigkeit
wird ja von allen gesehen die bundeswehr
war und ist ja in mehreren krisen
gleichzeitig eingesetzt bei der flut in
der pandemie und jetzt auch bei der
hilfe für die ukraine
hoffentlich bleibt das jetzt bei dem
fall aber auch darüber der weitere
forderung erhoben
ist da jetzt auch mit blick auf unsere
staatlichen strukturen alles im lot
jänner daran dass noch vor kurzem auch
die fdp gesagt hat wir brauchen eine
reform an haupt und gliedern
auch mit blick auf den staatsaufbau ja
also um allen die sorge zu nehmen
deutschland bleibt ein föderaler
bundesstaat aber wir merken ja dass in
krisen die sich kurzfristig aufbauen
die das bundesgebiet als ganzes
betreffen wir sagen wir mit loser
koordination manchmal nicht schnell
genug vorankommen
da ist natürlich die frage ob man bei
terror lagen naturkatastrophen nagen ob
man da nicht klare zuständigkeiten und
strukturen braucht der meinung bin ich
nach wie vor das ist aber etwas was man
ja nicht schneide ich in der
öffentlichkeitsarbeit
herausposaunen kann sondern da muss man
ja auch um vertrauen bei den ländern
werben wie wir nach innen unsere
kompetenzen klug gemeinsam koordinieren
vielleicht auch neue rechtsgrundlagen
schaffen wir hatten ja mal in der
letzten legislaturperiode
vorgeschlagen den die idee von ralph
brinkhaus dem damaligen cdu csu
fraktionsvorsitzender ernst zu nehmen
mal sozusagen eine weitere föderalismus
reform anzugehen wir haben immer wieder
betont wir sind dazu bereit
solche gespräche zu führen und das wäre
sicherlich nicht verkehrt sowohl was das
innere herausforderungen angeht und bei
der bundeswehr müssen wir sicherlich
aufpassen dass wir sie nicht
überlasten mit sozusagen
unterstützungsleistungen im innern und
gleichzeitig eine vielzahl von sehr
gefährlichen einsätzen im äußeren
sondern da müssen die aufgaben sich ein
stück weit in der waage halten mit dem
was eben an ausrüstung an mannschaft da
ist insbesondere wenn es um gefährliche
auslandseinsätze geht darf man die
truppe nicht systematisch überfordern
mal dass uns auch zu lasten der
sicherheit der soldatinnen und soldaten
gehen würde sie hatten quasi eine
stärkere zentralisierung in diesem
bereich innere äußere sicherheit mehr
als nur koordination angesprochen das
sehen sie ja teilweise auch in der
pandemie und in der bildungspolitik so
aber man könnte ja auch umgekehrt sagen
wir brauchen mehr echten föderalismus
mehr verantwortung für die länder also
ernst machen mit der staatlichkeit der
länder schauen sie da bin ich sehr offen
für insbesondere wenn um
das der subsidiarität oder auch die
bekämpfung von
gefahrenlagen mit umgrenzen ausbreitung
bereich geht ich habe mich erst in der
jüngsten vergangenheit dafür eingesetzt
dass wir
kompetenzen in die hände der länder
legen ich will jetzt mal etwas flapsig
sagen was auch immer man vorschlägt
kritik erntet man sowieso wenn man dinge
strafen möchte beklagt ein teil der
ministerpräsidenten und sagt dass
dagegen die eigenstaatlichkeit gibt man
kompetenzen zurück bekommt man
gelegentlich den vorwurf der bund mache
sich vom acker am ende muss man das tun
was man für richtig hält und vorschlagen
was man für richtig hält und das dann
durch argumentieren ein königsweg gibt
es bei solchen immer streit beladenen
fragen nie in dem sinne dass dann alle
hurra rufen eine solche lösung kann man
nur arbeiten wenn man sich auf eine idee
wie etwa eine weitere
föderalismuskommission oder eine weitere
für realismus reformen die dann auch von
brighton märkten getragen ist begibt
aber da glaube ich
sind noch zwei drei schritte nötig gibt
es noch andere vorhaben die sie sich als
ampel vorgenommen hatten die jetzt in
den hintergrund getreten sind aber die
sie trotzdem auf jeden fall anpacken
wollen was die änderung der verfassung
angeht beispiel wahlalter senken
wehrpflicht eher wahrscheinlich eher
nicht oder dienstpflicht aus ihrer sicht
nicht aber was muss an der verfassung
noch sonst getan werden um sie
zukunftsfest zu machen
es geht ja nicht immer sofort umfragen
das wohl und wehe zukunftsfähig oder
nicht sondern es geht mitunter auch
darum im verfassungstext
dinge klarzustellen vielleicht auch
dinge wo sich der verfassungstext ein
bisschen von der lebenswirklichkeit
entfernt hat vielleicht auch
nachzuziehen dazu gehört
beispielsweise das wir anstreben dem
begriff der terrasse aus dem grundgesetz
rauszunehmen nicht weil irgendjemand
glaubt dass der begriff in seiner
verwendung zur entstehungszeit des
grundgesetzes
in irgendeiner form diskriminierende
eingesetzt wurde aber wir haben heute
eben eine breite auch wissenschaftlich
getragene überzeugung dass so etwas wie
menschliche rasse nicht gibt und es gibt
rassismus den das gute das absolut den
das gesetz muss und deshalb muss der
auch weiterhin verboten ist
diskriminierungs merkmal werden aber es
ist halt schwierig wenn jemand vortragen
muss ich bin angehöriger einer rasse und
wäre deswegen werde deswegen
diskriminiert obwohl man eigentlich weiß
dass es keine rassen gibt das ist
sicherlich für die betroffenen ein
großes problem vielleicht nicht für die
gesellschaft als ganzes aber das
grundgesetz stellt der das individuum in
den mittelpunkt und wenn es hier
möglichkeiten gibt menschen die dieses
problem von den schultern zu nehmen kann
man sich dessen durchaus annehmen und
ähnliches gilt eben auch für andere
textpassagen nehmen sie die berühmten
kinderrechte auch da ist es natürlich so
kinder haben natürlich grundrechte weil
alle menschen grundrechte haben aber es
gibt immer mal wieder auch besondere
verfahrens lagen
wo die die rechte der kinder durch durch
sozusagen überwiegend an andere die
eltern im regelfall ist auch gut und
richtig so wahrgenommen werden aber den
anspruch zu haben dass man kinder
möglichst
sozusagen immer wie wie subjekte auch in
verfahren behandelt wo sie vielleicht
noch nicht selber vollständig ihren
willen und ihre rechte durchsetzen
können ist ein anliegen dass man
durchaus auch im verfassungstext
deutlich machen was aber wiederum die
gefahr dass paternalismus birgt oder
weil der staat womöglich sagt mehr noch
als die eltern was die was gut für die
kinder ist also das ist natürlich eine
große gefahr auf die man achten muss
dreiecks verhältnisse sind im
juristischen immer sehr gefährlich hier
im dreieck staat eltern und kinder und
sie können überzeugt sein wir als fdp
werden natürlich alles dafür tun dass
das erziehungsrecht der eltern nicht
eingeschränkt wird wir wollen nicht dass
der staat zum ober erzieher wird das
wäre in vielerlei hinsicht eine große
gefahr aber dass wir in der verfassung
deutlich machen dass wir den behörden
gegenüber kindern auftreten
einen kindgerechten umgang wählen dass
sie kinder angemessen auch im
verfahren
behandeln ihnen eine angemessene
stellung einräumen das finde ich
kommt gerade dem gedanken nach alle
menschen als individuen zu behandeln und
kinder eben auch angemessen zu behandeln
das finde ich ist ein
nachvollziehbarer und richtiger gedanke
wenn sie sagen das grundgesetz in die
zeit stellen an die veränderten
gesellschaftlichen verhältnisse anpassen
wie es dann mit ihrem vorhaben auch
verantwortungsgemeinschaft einzuführen
sozusagen das zusammenleben neu zu
regeln ist es nicht jetzt schon so dass
eigentlich der begriff des grundgesetzes
vom einfachgesetzlichen ehe begriff ab
weil sich die väter mütter was anderes
darunter vorgestellt haben nämlich er
die ehe von mann und frau als also
nichts gegen andere formen aber
sozusagen in diesem zusammenhang auch
ehe und familie gedacht haben wäre das
dann nicht ehrlicher das auch in die
verfassung zu schreiben wenn man das
jetzt anders sieht ich glaube
man würde einen großen
gesellschaftlichen
konflikt provozieren ohne not denn das
vorhaben
auf dass sie mich jetzt ansprechen die
verantwortungsgemeinschaft die steht ja
gar nicht in konkurrenz zur ehe wie sie
sich gerade die mütter und väter des
grundgesetzes vorgestellt haben das wird
immer wieder behauptet aber
die leute die ich im blick habe
beispielsweise ältere leute die eine
wohnungs gemeinschaft gründen um nicht
ins heim zu müssen oder alleinerziehende
die sich bei der kindererziehung
gegenseitig helfen die verbindet ja kein
erotisches band oder kein band der liebe
miteinander sondern die wollen sich
praktisch im alltag helfen die würden
nie im leben daran denken deswegen zu
heiraten das ist etwas anderes sondern
das ist sozusagen eine vielleicht durch
durch freundschaft gebundene
zweckvereinbarung also wir sind eher bei
gedanken wie wir sie ein bisschen im
gesellschaftsrecht haben wo man einem
nützlichen zweck verfolgen möchte und
dafür möchte ich den menschen die eben
kein geld verdienen wollen sondern sich
einfach den alltag etwas leichter machen
wollen sich beistehen wollen die
verantwortung füreinander übernehmen
wollen weil es ja im interesse einer
liberalen
ordnung ist das nicht der staat sofort
bei jedem problem eintritt sondern dass
die bürger eigene wege und möglichkeiten
haben um sich gegenseitig zu helfen das
ist eigentlich die zielgruppe für dieses
institut und das sind völlig andere
leute als menschen die darüber
nachdenken ob sie sich das jawort in der
kirche oder vor dem standesamt geben und
deshalb glaube ich gibt es da keinen
konflikt aber könnte man nicht sagen der
liberale staat hält sich hier zurück
weil ja jeder seine privaten beziehung
auf verantwortungs gemeinschaften das
zusammenleben erbschaft umgang selbst
regeln kann und dazu musste ich der
staat ein neues institut schaffen gut
wenn man diese diesem argument folgen
würde müsste man sich natürlich die
frage stellen warum gibt es so viele
verschiedene
formen im gesellschaftsrecht warum gibt
es personen und kapitalgesellschaften
warum gibt es innerhalb dieser gruppen
wieder die unterschiedlichsten
ausprägungen wie die gbr die ohg und so
weiter und so fort die antwort ist weil
in einer ausdifferenzierten gesellschaft
ist sehr unterschiedliche
interessenlagen gibt die auch alle
legitim sein können gerade weil der
staat eben nicht der zensor der
lebensentwürfe und der der lebens zwecke
ist und deshalb ist es im ökonomischen
bereich auf ab wird anerkannt dass die
rechtsordnung unterschiedliche vehikel
die auf diese unterschiedlichen
interessen konstellationen passen
anbietet um den dort tätigen das leben
etwas leichter zu machen und genauso
kann man natürlich im bereich das des
nicht-kommerziellen zusammenlebens wo
sich menschen einfach gegenseitig
unterstützen und helfen wollen nicht um
geld zu verdienen sondern aus der
motivation auch der freundschaft der
verbundenheit und auch der
hilfsbereitschaft heraus sich
gegenseitig unterstützen wollen warum
soll man denen nicht auch passende
vehikel anbieten für mich ist das
eigentlich absolut plausibel wenn man
diesen ökonomischen mit dem eher
privaten bereich palais sitzt noch eine
frage in die zukunft gewandt die fdp hat
ja jedenfalls auch in der ampelkoalition
die gesamte ampel sich dafür
ausgesprochen auf einen europäischen
bundesstaat hinzuarbeiten das würde ja
auf eine auflösung deutschlands in
dieser größeren form einer floralen
formen meinetwegen aber einen
bundesstaat mit einem gliedstaat
deutschland hinauslaufen wie stellen sie
sich das vor gerade in diesen zeiten in
denen wir ja jetzt stärker mit den
nationalstaaten und deren wehrhaftigkeit
und 100 milliarden für die bundeswehr
konfrontiert sind also es ist natürlich
so in der gegenwart muss man mit den
strukturen arbeiten die gelten das
erfordert schon der respekt vor dem
geltenden recht auch vor dem geltenden
verfassungs und europarecht aber es ist
ja schon die aufgabe von parteien
durchaus visionen zu entwickeln und das
ist natürlich ein sehr langer weg aber
dass man sich natürlich überlegt wie
entwickelt man das europäische projekt
das ja von vielen gescholten wurde aber
sich gerade in diesen tagen ja wieder
zeigt dass es ein friedensprojekt ist
das ist ein projekt der gegenseitigen
absicherung ist in einer welt die eben
leider nicht nur friedlich ist das
glaube ich ist
richtig darüber nachzudenken und das ist
sicherlich eher eine langfristige vision
als jetzt innerhalb einer
legislaturperiode zu regeln aber ich
glaube dass es richtig ist aber dass
solche langfristigen dinge auch
nachzudenken und wie sehen sie gerade
die lage flüchtlinge eingreifen auch in
der ukraine mit blick auf die
europäische dimension noch mal verstärkt
also zeigt dass er das wir zusammen
wachsen oder gerade nicht also die
verteilungsfrage die gerechte verteilung
die quoten frage ein gemeinsames
asylrecht sie geht der zug jetzt gerade
in richtung einheit oder in richtung
lockerer staatenverbund ja also wir
bräuchten eigentlich dort klare regeln
aber dabei ist die maus keinen faden ab
das sind natürlich sehr schwierige
debatten auch nicht erst seit
der aktuellen flüchtlingsbewegung
sondern schon seit jahren und natürlich
wäre es gut wenn wir klare regeln hätten
wer in einer notsituation welche
beiträge leistet dann könnte man
leichter planen dann könnte man auch
schneller handeln dann könnte man auch
schneller kapazitäten aufbauen und
transportlogistik organisieren das
klingt jetzt alles wahnsinnig
technokratisch ist aber eben notwendige
bedingungen dafür dass ging in einer
schwierigen situation einfach
funktionieren und da wäre das schon sehr
hilfreich weil ja auch die forderung
erhoben wodurch einer europäischen armee
was hier voraussetzt dass letztlich
vielleicht auch irgendwann das
europäische parlament über den einsatz
von deutschen soldaten entscheiden wenn
man das auch als parlamentsarmee denkt
ist das sozusagen es wurde ja auch von
der fdp als treiber vorgeschlagen ist
das in der zukunft realistisch also es
ist natürlich so wenn wir uns anschauen
welchen aufwand alle einzelstaaten für
ihre armeen betreiben und wie viel sagen
wir mal
kampfkraft oder wer fähigkeit daraus
resultiert dann würde man natürlich
feststellen wenn man diese ressourcen
zusammenlegen würde dass das sehr viel
effizienter wäre und wenn wir uns
langfristig auf dem weg hin zu einer
immer engeren union begeben ist
natürlich die
zusammenlegung von
militärischen kapazitäten der richtige
weg das wird ja in einzelnen schritten
auch schon getan denken sie entweder
anders das deutsch-niederländische korps
und solche dinge also das wird schon
erprobt und eins ist natürlich klar das
ist unsere feste politische überzeugung
über die über krieg und frieden wird
nicht in geheimen entschieden sondern
über krieg und frieden über den einsatz
der armee muss das parlament in
öffentlicher transparente debatte
entscheiden und deshalb muss es so sein
dass alle armeen
parlaments armeen sind jedenfalls wenn
es nach unserer überzeugung geht das
gilt natürlich dann auch für die
europäische armee aber der bundestag
muss dafür zuständig bleiben die
bundeswehr zu mandatieren so ist es und
wenn wir über solche
langfristigen perspektiven wie
europäischer bundesstaat und europäische
armee sprechen dann ist natürlich klar
dass damit eine grundlegende reform auch
der verfassungs strukturen einhergehen
müsste und bis es soweit ist ist es gut
und richtig dass der bundestag als das
demokratisch legitimierte parlament über
den einsatz der bundeswehr entscheidet
wer davon weg gehen will will den
charakter der bundeswehr verändern und
wenn es nach mir geht wäre das kein
fortschritt noch ein rückschritt
herzlichen dank herr buschmann für
dieses gespräch
[Musik]
in unserem heutigen faz einspruch
podcast spezial beschäftigen wir uns mit
dem grundgesetz in der zeitenwende und
dazu gehört auch die befassung mit der
wehr fähigkeit der gesellschaft und auch
mit der wehrpflicht denn das haben
einige politiker gefordert es ging sogar
bis hin zur dienstpflicht sogar bodo
ramelow ministerpräsident von thüringen
und angehöriger der linkspartei hat sich
dazu geäußert positiv geäußert was hat
das denn mit dem grundgesetz zu tun
erklärt naja die wehrpflicht ist ja
immer noch im grundgesetz enthalten wir
haben da ja den artikel 12a des
grundgesetzes und darin steht dass alle
männer vom vollendeten achtzehnten
lebensjahr an zum dienst in den
streitkräften verpflichtet werden können
genau das habe ich auch mit gewinn am
eigenen leibe gespürt aber die
wehrpflicht ist ja nun seit 2011
ausgesetzt nur auf einfach gesetzlicher
ebene
das grundgesetz wurde dafür nicht
geändert der bundestag hat damals
lediglich in das wehrpflichtgesetz
hineingeschrieben dass die wehrpflicht
nur noch für den spannungs und für den
verteidigungsfall geht nun wird
deutschland der sich direkt angegriffen
aber man könnte bei einem ersten blick
vielleicht auf den gedanken kommen dass
wir ein spannungsvoller haben für den
spannungsvoll reicht eine allgemein
angespannte weltlage aber nicht aus der
spannungs fall ist in artikel 80 a des
grundgesetzes enthalten und er wird als
vorstufe zum verteidigungsfall
verstanden und muss mit
zweidrittelmehrheit im bundestag
festgestellt werden der
verteidigungsfall ist dann in artikel
115 grundgesetz definiert auch hier ist
wieder eine zweidrittelmehrheit im
bundestag erforderlich um den
festzustellen und sogar noch eine
zustimmung des bundesrates und all dies
wurde bisher nicht festgestellt also der
ukraine krieg führt nicht dazu dass wir
uns in so einem spannungsvoll befinden
die wehrpflicht ist nur ausgesetzt das
heißt sie kann jederzeit auch eingeführt
werden wieder ohne dass die verfassung
irgendwie angetastet werden muss genau
also es gibt da natürlich
unterschiedliche möglichkeiten einmal
könnte man ja einfach sagen wir ändern
wieder das wehrpflichtgesetz machen also
diese aussetzung und 2011 einfach
rückgängig und dann würde die
wehrpflicht wieder so gelten wie früher
allerdings daneben nur für männer und
das wird politisch unterschiedlich
bewertet auch schon seit langem
politisch unterschiedlich bewertet es
gibt einige die das für nicht mehr
zeitgemäß halten andere argumentieren
dass frauen ja auch zb durch die geburt
von kindern einer besonderen belastung
ausgesetzt sind und es dann auch fair
ist wenn man männer an anderer stelle
stärker belastet aber ja wenn eben an
diesen weg wählen würde dann würde die
wehrpflicht nur für männer gelten wenn
man die wehrpflicht für frauen auch
trotz ihrer gegenargumente die ja auch
beträchtlich sind wieder einführen
müsste müsste man aber an das
grundgesetz heran genau dann muss man
ans grundgesetz heran und man könnte da
an unterschiedliche stellen herangehen
zum einen könnte man sich natürlich
diesen wehrpflicht artikel vornehmen und
könnte da einfach rein schreiben dass
eben die wehrpflicht auch für frauen
gelten kann die meisten befürworten aber
mittlerweile an das verbot des arbeits
zwangs heranzugehen das bedeutet eine
allgemeine dienstpflicht einzuführen
das halten viele auch jetzt ganz
unabhängig von der geschlechterfrage für
den ehrlicheren weg weil es war ja auch
schon so als die wehrpflicht noch ihre
volle gültigkeit hatte dass längst nicht
alle zur bundeswehr sind es gab ja dann
eben für menschen die das nicht mit
ihrem gewissen vereinbaren konnten die
möglichkeit des zivildienstes und diese
gewissens überprüfung die früher mal
relativ hohe anforderungen hatte wurde
dann schon immer mehr zurückgefahren und
deshalb sagen manche na ja faktisch war
das eigentlich schon so was wie eine
dienstpflicht und dann könnten das doch
eigentlich auch in die verfassung
schreiben des arbeitslagers selbe wie
zwangsarbeit
arbeitszwang ist nicht dasselbe wie
zwangsarbeit also wir haben daher zwei
unterschiedliche regelungen grundgesetz
beide in dem artikel 12 und die sind in
unterschiedlichen absetzen das
bundesverfassungsgericht prüft die zwar
zusammen
aber beim arbeitszwang das merkt man
auch allen ausnahme tatbeständen wird
eben an so was wie eine dienstpflicht
gedacht dass steht er auch jetzt schon
drin dass es ausnahmen geben kann für so
genannte herkömmliche dienstleistungs
pflichten das ist aber eher sowas wie
feuerwehr oder deich hilfe was es schon
sehr lange gibt nicht eine neu
eingeführte allgemeine dienstpflicht bei
zwangsarbeit da wird nach ganz
herrschender meinung davon ausgegangen
dass eine entwürdigende behandlung dazu
kommen müsste dass es also nicht das
worüber wir hier sprechen das war jetzt
ein guter überblick über die rechtliche
debatte vielen dank und jetzt sprechen
sie mit romantik den präsidenten des
hessischen staatsgerichtshofs aber auch
nicht nur über die wehrpflicht genau
über die wehrpflicht gar nicht sondern
ein bisschen über die bundeswehr weil es
ja auch ein sondervermögen zur
bundeswehr geben soll und das große
thema mit roman bozek wird eben
sondervermögen sein einmal zum
klimaschutz da ist ja ein
nachtragshaushalt auf bundesebene
verabschiedet worden und wir gucken uns
an ob man bestimmte erfahrungen aus
hessen für die rechtliche bewertung
dieses nachtragshaushalts übertragen
kann und dann wird es eben auch um das
sondervermögen zur bundeswehr gehen und
direkt danach folgt das gespräch mit udo
di fabio
[Musik]
ja bei mir im studio ist jetzt roman
post präsident des hessischen
staatsgerichtshofs und des
oberlandesgerichts frankfurt und auch
honorar professor an der eps universität
in wiesbaden ich hatte ja schon zu
beginn der sendung gesagt es ist quasi
was besonderes dass wir auch mal einen
gast hier direkt im studio haben das
freut uns natürlich besonders hallo herr
poß guten tag herr kleiner ja ich bin
sehr gerne zu ihnen gekommen freue mich
dass wir uns persönlich und erhalten
können ja wir wollen uns über das thema
sondervermögen unterhalten das ist ja
ein schlagwort was zurzeit in
verschiedenen punkten so ein bisschen
durch die presse kursiert und sie haben
sich im herbst vergangenen jahres ganz
intensiv mit dem sondervermögen
beschäftigt weil es damals in hessen ein
sogenanntes gute zukunft sicherungs
gesetz gab und darin war ein
sondervermögen enthalten dass der
bewältigung der korona pandemie dienen
sollte und als ausnahme zur in der
hessischen landesverfassung enthaltenen
schuldenbremse fungieren sollte und der
hessische staatsgerichtshof hat gesagt
das geht in dieser form nicht warum
haben sie das gesagt in der tat haben
wir mit unserer entscheidung am 27
oktober festgestellt dass das in essen
geschaffene corona sondervermögen mit
der hessischen verfassung nicht
vereinbar ist das hat im wesentlichen
zwei gründe zum einen haben wir die hier
gewählte konstruktion des
sondervermögens als nicht
verfassungskonform angesehen vor allem
deshalb weil diese art des
sondervermögens wie sie hier geschaffen
wurde aus unserer sicht gegen das
budgetrecht des landtages verstoßen hat
und auf der anderen seite haben wir
einen verstoß gegen die schuldenbremse
angenommen wobei wir durchaus mit
gegangen sind dass hier eine besondere
note situation infolge der korona
pandemie gegeben ist der die auch eine
durchbrechung der schuldenbremse
rechtfertigt aber wir haben gesagt dass
für die kredit finanzierten maßnahmen
immer ein unmittelbarer zusammenhang zu
der notsituation erforderlich ist ein
sogenannter konkreter
veranlassungszusammenhang und da waren
wir der auffassung dass doch einige
kredit finanzierte maßnahmen über diese
unmittelbare krisenbewältigung auch
hinausgegangen sind und das war der
zweite anknüpfungspunkt warum wir gesagt
haben dieses sondervermögen ist mit der
hessischen verfassung nicht vereinbar
wir sind insoweit das erste
verfassungsgericht in deutschland
gewesen dass sich mit der schuldenbremse
mit ihren grundsätzen und vor allen
dingen aber auch mit den möglichkeiten
und grenzen der durchbrechung der
schuldenbremse zu beschäftigen hatte ja
und diese vorarbeit die sie da auf
landesebene in hessen geleistet haben
die könnte jetzt auf bundes- eben eine
ziemlich relevant werden denn da gibt es
ja schon etwas was zumindest auf den
ersten blick daran erinnern könnte wir
haben ja da die situation dass es jetzt
ein nachtragshaushalt gab und in diesem
nachtragshaushalt wurde neben 60
milliarden euro an den energie und
klimafonds
übertragen auch als sondervermögen und
ja die bundesregierung
begründet diese übertragung damit dass
eben das ganze auch zur bewältigung der
korona pandemie diene weil es um die
korona pandemie zu bewältigen
wirtschaftliche anreize brauche und
diese wirtschaftlichen anreize die
könnten eben besonders beim thema
klimaschutz gesetzt werden ist das eine
zulässige argumentationskette also eine
abschließende bewertung würde ich mir an
der stelle nicht anmaßen wir haben in
hessen über das sondervermögen in hessen
zu entscheiden gehabt und über das was
jetzt auf bundesebene geschieht wird ja
nach allem was man hört das
bundesverfassungsgericht zu entscheiden
haben denn es ist ja angekündigt dass es
einen normenkontrollantrag geben soll
und ich denke das ist auch eine gute
gelegenheit für unser höchstes gericht
für das bundesverfassungsgericht
maßstäbe der schuldenbremse auch
klarzustellen
ich verstehe schon dass es für die
politik in anbetracht der vielzahl der
herausforderungen die im moment anstehen
ausgesprochen schwierig ist die vorgaben
der schuldenbremse auch tatsächlich
einzuhalten und ich denke das wird ein
spannungsfeld sein was jetzt in den
nächsten wochen und monaten eher noch
zunehmen wird wenn man sich auch gerade
noch ganz neue krisen und entwicklungen
anschaut aber die schuldenbremse steht
im grundgesetz in artikel 115 sie steht
in der hessischen verfassung sie steht
in vielen anderen landesverfassungen und
damit ist sie ein verfassungsrechtliches
gebot und nicht nur eine unverbindliche
richtschnur und die schuldenbremse
bedeutet dass der ausgeglichene haushalt
der regelfall ist
gleichzeitig beinhaltet das auch das an
eine durchbrechung der schuldenbremse
hohe anforderungen zu stellen sind und
es jedenfalls der ausnahmecharakter ist
das noch kredit finanzierte maßnahmen
ergriffen werden von daher ist die
schuldenbremse auch eine bewusste
beeinträchtigung politische
gestaltungsspielräume gewesen jedenfalls
soweit eben kredite aufgenommen werden
die politik wollte einen
paradigmenwechsel damit herbeiführen im
interesse der nachhaltigkeit und dem
interesse auch der nachfolgenden
generation von daher ist das jedenfalls
nicht so einfach die schuldenbremse zu
durchbrechen und diesen anlass dann zu
nehmen jetzt beliebig geld auszugeben
ich habe mich schon etwas gewundert in
der diskussion vor allen dingen im
letzten jahr als immer wieder die rede
davon war die schuldenbremse ist jahr
2022 noch ausgesetzt also kann man
praktisch beliebig schulden machen das
ist aus meiner sicht nicht der richtige
umgang mit der schuldenbremse denn die
durchbrechung der schuldenbremse ist an
eine ganz bestimmte notsituation
gebunden und deshalb müssen die
kreditfinanzierten maßnahmen final auch
auf die beseitigung dieser notsituation
gerichte zahlen und das ist bei der
korona pandemie sicherlich bei ganz
vielen maßnahmen eindeutig das war im
übrigen auch in hessen eindeutig wenn es
um medizinische dinge geht auch wenn es
um ausgleichszahlungen geht von branchen
die unmittelbar durch die pandemie
betroffen sind dann dürfte das kein
keine frage sein dass insoweit auch
dieser finale zusammenhang zwischen
notsituationen und kreditfinanzierten
maßnahmen gegeben ist ob das jetzt auf
bundesebene noch so eingehalten ist wenn
jetzt eben corona gelder für den
klimaschutz eingesetzt werden das ist
sicherlich ein offener punkt ein sehr
diskussions bedürftiger punkte ist ja
auch schon im haushaltsausschuss durch
sachverständige auch kontrovers bewertet
worden es gibt auch eine bewertung des
wissenschaftlichen dienstes des
deutschen bundestages vom januar die
sich im übrigen auch sehr ausführlich
mit den anforderungen die wir im
hessischen staatsgerichtshof aufgestellt
haben auseinandersetzt ich will es mal
so sagen um wirklich auch keine
endgültige bewertung davor zu nehmen es
ist mindestens mal ein
verfassungsrechtlicher grenzfall
erkennbar ist allerdings schon dass die
bundesregierung in ihrer begründung und
auch das parlament in der begründung
nicht allein darauf abgestellt hat dass
man jetzt die gelder ja gerade mal habe
sondern man hat ja schon den
zusammenhang zur corona pandemie
hergestellt oder vielleicht etwas
zurückhaltender formuliert versucht
herzustellen indem man eben sagte sind
klima investitionen wegen corona
unterblieben und die müssen jetzt
deshalb auch nachgeholt werden ob dieser
zusammenhang beträgt das muss das
bundesverfassungsgericht zu gegebener
zeit entscheiden also auch aus hessen
auch aus den erfahrungen unserer
rechtsprechung blicken wir da durchaus
mit mit großem interesse darauf ob das
sozusagen noch ein ein tauglicher einen
hinreichend enger
zusammenhang ist was gab es in hessen
für maßnahmen die die landesregierung
versucht hat mit der korona pandemie zu
begründen wo sie dann gesagt haben da
ist jetzt dieser
veranlassungszusammenhang nicht mehr
gegeben das reicht uns jetzt nicht aus
es war insgesamt das problem in dem
hessischen gesetz dass vieles sehr
unbestimmt war und schon im gesetz
deshalb nicht so ganz klar erkennbar war
ob alles was jetzt damit finanziert wird
auch tatsächlich corona bezug hat wenn
davon soziale infrastruktur die rede ist
dann kann man sehr viel darunter
verstehen oder auch von bei kulturellen
maßnahmen also da wäre es auf unser aus
unserer sicht zumindest schon mal im
gesetz auch erforderlich gewesen den
chor ohne bezug präzise zu beschreiben
als es geschehen ist man muss der
politik an der stelle auch wirklich
zugute halten dass sie natürlich damals
sehr schnell handeln musste und dass es
vor allen dingen auch noch an
verfassungsrechtlichen leitplanken
gefehlt hat also wir haben mit unserer
entscheidung auch neuland betreten und
als erste eben hier
verfassungsrechtliche maßstäbe gesetzt
und ich denke
jetzt auf bundesebene wird das
vielleicht auch noch weiter kontrolliert
werden wir haben auch gesagt dass wir
uns als verfassungsgericht jetzt nicht
jede einzelmaßnahme auch konkret
anschauen das ist sicherlich auch nicht
unsere aufgabe
besonders umstritten in hessen waren
beispielsweise kredit finanzierte
maßnahmen im hinblick auf fahrradwege
beleuchtung
fahrradstellplätze und solche sachen das
mögen alles auch ganz wichtige sachen
sein dass es gar keine frage aber wir
müssen uns immer wieder vergegenwärtigen
wir reden hier über schulden und
schulden sollen eigentlich durch die
einführung der schuldenbremse der
vergangenheit angehören und deshalb sind
da die anforderungen sehr hoch und das
sind schon maßnahmen bei denen man
jedenfalls nicht auf den ersten blick
sieht dass das jetzt tatsächlich mit der
korona pandemie und insbesondere dem
ziel ihrer bewältigung auch in
zusammenhang steht es gab auch
maßnahmen im bereich der landwirtschaft
die zumindest umstritten waren ich war
am vergangenen wochenende in
norddeutschland an der nordsee hat dort
im ostfriesen kurier gelesen dass das
land niedersachsen aus corona
sondervermögen eine kappen pool maschine
über mehrere millionen euro unterstützt
auch das mag sehr sehr wichtig sein aber
zumindest jetzt mit dem blickwinkel den
ich aus hessen habe und eben unserer
entscheidung wundere ich mich schon ein
bisschen wie gesagt ich verstehe die
politik dass sie gestalten möchte dass
sie viele aufgaben auch zu bewältigen
hat aber die schuldenbremse ist ein
verfassungsgebot und wir reden hier um
schulden über schulden die im zweifel
dann von nachfolgenden generationen
gezahlt werden müssen oder jedenfalls
von geldern die vielleicht für andere
dinge dann nicht mehr zur verfügung
stehen jetzt sind die beispiele die sie
genannt haben also zum beispiel diese
fahrradwege oder fahrradstellplätze ja
genau solche
klimaschutzmaßnahmen die man
möglicherweise auf bundesebene eben auch
aus diesem klima fonds finanzieren
könnte war dann die begründung der
bundesregierung für sie so was wie ein
déjà vu die bundesregierung oder der
bund ist die ganze zeit schon relativ
großzügig in dem umgang mit diesen
mitteln das ist ja auch kein phänomen
jetzt der neuen bundesregierung sondern
das hat auch meines wissens auch schon
die alte bundesregierung gemacht auch da
sind ja in erheblichem umfang schulden
zur bewältigung der korona pandemie
aufgenommen worden
und dann ist damit ein sogenannter
booster für die wirtschaft verbunden
gewesen
auf der einen seite ist natürlich
anzuerkennen dass die korona pandemie
auch wirtschaftliche auswirkungen hat
und deshalb das interesse auch der
wirtschaft unter die arme zu greifen ist
schon irgendwie auch nachvollziehbar auf
der anderen seite ist natürlich auch die
frage wo hat das grenzen also kann ich
weil die korona pandemie eine
durchbrechung der schuldenbremse
rechtfertigt was wir auch in hessen
grundsätzlich angenommen haben beliebige
wirtschaftsförderung betreiben durch
kredite das da meine ich jedenfalls und
das ist auch die linie unserer
rechtsprechung dass es da grenzen geben
muss auch grenzen unter dem
gesichtspunkt der erforderlichkeit und
auch der angemessenheit
die grenzziehungen allerdings das will
ich auch einräumen sind durchaus auch
schwierig und ich halte es auch für
wichtig und das steht auch in unserer
entscheidung dass man schon auch dem
gesetzgeber einen spielraum einräumen
muss das ist aus meiner sicht auch für
das verhältnis der staatsgewalten
zueinander wichtig aber es ist dann
schon auch wichtig dass der gesetzgeber
auch im gesetzgebungsverfahren
begründet warum er welche maßnahmen zur
bewältigung der pandemie oder der
notsituation konkret für erforderlich
hält und diese begründung erfordernisse
die wir in unserer entscheidung auch
stark hervorgehoben haben sind in hessen
jedenfalls bei der schaffung dieses
corona sondervermögens so aus unserer
sicht auch nicht eingehalten gewesen
leichter als begründung aus wenn man
eben sagt na ja wir brauchen mehr
wirtschaftliches wachstum jetzt wieder
nach der korona pandemie und im bereich
klima stehen wir vor einer großen
transformation
deshalb hat das eine besondere
symbolische bedeutung und deshalb müssen
wir jetzt eben 60 milliarden in diesen
klimafonds schieben ist das ausreichend
oder müsste man da konkreter werden also
ich will zumindest mal so sagen ich
halte es für grenzwertig ich maße mir
keine abschließende beurteilung an ich
bin nicht für den boden zuständig und
wie gesagt das müssen andere zu
gegebener zeit entscheiden die das mit
sicherheit auch gut entscheiden können
aber allein die aussage dass klimaschutz
wichtig ist was er zweifellos ist wird
sicherlich nicht genügen also da muss
man aus meiner sicht schon auch den
geist der schuldenbremse auch
berücksichtigen der eben schuldenmachen
zu klaren verfassungsrechtlichen
ausnahme erklärt hat und dann muss eben
auch wirklich eine ausnahme
konstellation vorliegen und als juristen
wenden wir ausnahmen in der regel auch
eng und restriktiv an und deshalb meine
ich schon dass man mit diesen weiten
begründungen an der stelle auch sehr
vorsichtig sein muss ich sehe dann auch
eigentlich kaum noch eine grenze
dann kann man im zweifel auch crooner
gelder für rüstungsgüter für
flüchtlingshilfe oder für viele andere
themen auch umwidmen und ich glaube dann
verwischen doch dinge dass die politik
hier einen vor allem dilemma steht da
ist gar keine frage weil die erwartungen
hoch sind weil es sehr viele
herausforderungen im moment gibt die
auch sehr viel geld kosten
das dass das räume ich ein aber ich
denke schon dass wir eine ehrliche
diskussion brauchen und zu dieser
diskussion gehört für mich auch dass man
schon auch über die zukunftsfähigkeit
der schuldenbremse diskutieren kann sie
ist ja 2009 in das grundgesetz
aufgenommen worden vor dem hintergrund
der finanzkrise
die herausforderung die wir aktuell
haben von klimaschutz über corona bis
ukraine waren damals so natürlich nicht
absehbar von daher muss sich die politik
schon fragen ob sie auch in anbetracht
dieser herausforderungen an der
schuldenbremse festhalten kann und will
die schuldenbremse ist nicht in stein
gemeißelt sie unterliegt nicht der
ewigkeitsgarantie des grundgesetzes sie
könnte durchaus auch geändert oder
abgeschwächt werden die das
sondervermögen für die bundeswehr das
jetzt geschaffen werden soll soll ja
auch eine ausnahme zur schuldenbremse
sein
natürlich kann die politik auch über
ausgabenkürzungen oder
einnahmeerhöhungen nachdenken was ich
allerdings auch aus
verfassungsrechtlicher sicht für
schwierig halte wenn die politik die
grenzen der schuldenbremse beliebig
austestet und möglicherweise auch
überschreitet und damit an der stelle
eine frage wieder einmal sehr stark den
verfassungsgerichten über antwortet wird
die möglicherweise doch primär erst
einmal der politischen diskussion und
die sie ohne bedürfen würde
auf das sondervermögen für die
bundeswehr kommen wir gleich doch weil
das ja auch verfassungsrechtlich so ein
bisschen noch mal speziell zu bewerten
ist weiter sehr direkt ins grundgesetz
hineingeschrieben werden soll ich würde
gerne noch mal bei diesem thema wo sind
eigentlich die grenzen bleiben da haben
sie ja versucht mit diesem konkreten
veranlassungszusammenhang so eine hilfe
zumindest zu setzen wie man die grenze
ziehen kann in der anhörung im
haushaltsausschuss des bundestages ist
der staatsrechtler alexander thiele
damit ziemlich deutlich ja man könnte
sagen ins gericht gegangen oder hat das
stark kritisiert er hat gesagt also
sinngemäß zumindest es ist eigentlich
gar kein richtiges kriterium es führt
nicht so richtig weiter weil irgendwie
bei so großen krisen wie der korona
pandemie hat ja eigentlich alles mit
allem zu tun es gibt kein lebensbereich
der jetzt nicht von corona betroffen war
und er führt eigentlich ihr kriterium
gar nicht was sagen sie zu dieser kritik
ich teile diese einschätzung nicht und
sie ist jedenfalls ein widerspruch zu
der entscheidung die wir im hessischen
staatsgerichtshof im oktober des letzten
jahres getroffen haben ich kann diese
sicht politisch nachvollziehen ich kann
sie auch ökonomisch nachvollziehen ich
halte sie aber juristisch für falsch ich
halte sie für verfassungsrechtlich
falsch weil sie aus meiner sicht der dem
hintergrund dem inhalt dem sinn und
zweck der schuldenbremse in artikel 115
des grundgesetzes
widerspricht
die der ausgeglichene haushalt ist der
verfassungsrechtliche regelfall nach dem
grundgesetz so hat es der
verfassungsgebung 2009 entschieden und
ausnahmen müssen deshalb an sehr strenge
regeln geknüpft werden und das was hier
im haushaltsausschuss vertreten wurde
geht meines erachtens deutlich über
diesen ausnahmecharakter hinaus das ist
letztlich dann ein ein freibrief für die
politik nur aus anlass einer
notsituation alles schuldenfinanziert zu
machen und das ist meines erachtens auch
nicht das was der ausnahmecharakter der
durchbrechung der schuldenbremse in
folge einer notsituation meint es ist
eben eine ausnahme und dann sind an die
notsituation strenge anforderungen zu
stellen aber auch an das was
schuldenfinanziert infolge der
notsituation gemacht wird und dann
können nicht beliebig kredite
aufgenommen werden weil man vielleicht
gerade eine vielzahl von aufgaben mal
zufällig aus anlass dieser notsituation
bewältigen muss nein wir haben sehr klar
gestellt dass eben hier ein ganz
konkreter unmittelbarer
veranlassungszusammenhang bestehen muss
freies wort future sagt die klimakrise
wie sie von freddys verfügter genannt
wird ist genauso eine notsituation wie
die korona pandemie darf man da nicht
für den klimaschutz genauso schulden
machen wie für corona also zunächst mal
müsste die feststellung der notsituation
ja durch das parlament erfolgen das ist
meines erachtens so noch nicht
vorgenommen worden ohne zweifel ist die
klimakrise eine große herausforderung
ob sie allerdings tatsächlich der dem
tatbestandsmerkmal der notsituation nach
dem artikel 115 entspricht erscheint mir
zumindest auch ein stückweit fraglich
also das müsste man sich mit sicherheit
genauer anschauen aber wie gesagt man
müsste an der stelle in jedem fall auch
schritt für schritt vorgehen und müsste
sich dann auch klar dazu bekennen an
dieser stelle auch die schuldenbremse
außer kraft zu setzen ich glaube wir
haben eine vielzahl ganz wichtiger
aufgaben steht die klimakrise ja nicht
alleine es gibt auch andere aufgaben die
für die gesellschaft ganz wichtig sind
für unsere zukunft elementar sind die im
übrigen auch verfassungsrang genießen
aber es ist nicht der inhalt der
schuldenbremse das für jede wichtige
aufgabe hat sie auch verfassungsrang die
schuldenbremse zu unterlaufen werden
kann also grundsätzlich müssen auch alle
kernaufgaben alle zukunftsaufgaben mit
den mitteln die der haushalt ohne
schulden zur verfügung stellt bewältigt
werden können das ist das was 2009 ins
grundgesetz geschrieben wurde und man
hat das ja auch nicht ohne grund gemacht
man wollte ja die abhängigkeit von den
finanzmärkten infolge der finanzkrise
lösen und man wollte der politik des
ständigen schuldenmachens die ja auch
unser land geprägt hat nicht so stark
wie vielleicht andere länder aber man
wollte diese politik im interesse
nachfolgender generationen
verändern nun haben wir im moment eine
phase auch niedriger zinsen deshalb
fällt vielleicht auch leichter schulden
zu machen aber auch das mag sich ja mal
irgendwann ändern und das ist jetzt kein
strecken verfassungsrechtliches argument
aber man sollte sich jedenfalls nicht
von der überlegung lösen das alles was
schulden sind irgendwann eigentlich auch
mal zurückgezahlt werden muss und
jedenfalls die finanziellen
möglichkeiten nachfolgender generationen
auch nachfolgender politischer
generationen auch stark beeinträchtigen
kann bei der bundeswehr das ist ja
sozusagen gibt zweite große baustelle wo
jetzt dieses thema sondervermögen eine
rolle spielt möchte die bundesregierung
jetzt einen anderen weg gehen als beim
klimaschutz ist gab es also nicht
einfach nur ein nachtragshaushalt wo
dann eben gesagt wurde wir machen quasi
mit dem grund corona pandemie noch mal
ein maßnahmenpaket sondern das
sondervermögen für die bundeswehr das
soll explizit in die verfassung
geschrieben werden ist es damit auf
jeden fall verfassungsgemäß das müssen
andere beurteilen
mal sehen ob die frage vor das
bundesverfassungsgericht kommt klar ist
das natürlich eine verankerung im
grundgesetz ein sehr starkes
verfassungsrechtliches fundament ist und
das ist ja glaube ich genau der plan
dass man das eben auch mit der
zweidrittelmehrheit entsprechend
absichern will und damit hat dieses
sondervermögen auch einen besonderen
verfassungsrang will aber an der stelle
schon darauf hinweisen dass natürlich
der begriff des sondervermögens immer
ein wenig euphemistisch ist auch an
dieser stelle gilt dass das natürlich
schulden sind das soll ja auch dieses
sondervermögen jedenfalls zum ganz
wesentlichen teil durch kreditaufnahmen
finanziert werden
sondervermögen sind möglich das steht
auch im grundgesetz das haben wir im
übrigen auch in hessen angenommen obwohl
in der hessischen verfassung kein
artikel zum sondervermögen enthalten ist
aber wir haben ausdrücklich auch in
unserer entscheidung gesagt
grundsätzlich kann das sondervermögen
geben aber wie im juristischen so oft es
kommt dann auch auf die konkrete
ausgestaltung an sondervermögen stehen
jedenfalls in einem
verfassungsrechtlichen spannungsfeld zu
haushalts verfassungsgrundsätze
beispielsweise der
vollständigkeit der klarheit des
haushaltes aber auch zum budgetrecht des
parlaments
von daher wird es auch bei dem
sondervermögen bundeswehr darauf
ankommen dass die entscheidungen
tatsächlich auch vom parlament selbst
getroffen werden das bedeutet also auch
dass die die zwecke des sondervermögens
die verwendung der mittel
möglichst präzise auch schon im
parlamentarischen verfahren geregelt
werden sollte es ist immer dann
problematisch wenn die verantwortung
sehr stark der exekutive überlagert wird
was die mittel für ausgaben angeht das
war eben auch das problem bei dem
hessischen sondervermögen und das
budgetrecht des parlaments ist
jedenfalls ein kern recht unseres
parlamentarismus dessen man sich nicht
so ohne weiteres begeben kann was die
durchleitung dass wenn ich da vielleicht
mal ein haken darf heißt dass man müsste
dann auch konkrete mitbestimmungs
mechanismen
implementieren wenn man jetzt sagt man
schreibt dieses sondervermögen für die
bundeswehr ins grundgesetz hinein muss
man dann gleichzeitig auch mit rein
schreiben wie die abgeordnete neben
mitbestimmen können wie das geld
ausgegeben wird also je präziser umso
besser will ich mal allgemein sagen also
was sicherlich problematisch wäre was
aber ja auch nicht vorgesehen ist dass
man einfach nur ins grundgesetz oder ins
einfache gesetz schreibt es gibt eine
bundeswehr sondervermögen über 100
milliarden euro und über die
verausgabung der mittel entscheidet im
einzelnen die
bundesverteidigungsministerium das wäre
sicherlich mit der parlamentarischen
verantwortung und verankerung nicht
vereinbar wie konkret dann die
verankerung ans parlament erfolgt das
muss man natürlich im einzelfall sehen
das hängt natürlich auch von von den
möglichkeiten ab ich meine eine
besonderheit des sondervermögens ist
natürlich auch dass das in der regel
über jerich angelegt ist das ja auch die
attraktivität für die politik so ein
sondervermögen zu bilden während der
haushalt grundsätzlich dem jährlich
kites prinzip unterliegt kann eben das
sondervermögen auch für mehrere jahre
geschaffen werden dass man da
wahrscheinlich auch nicht alles schon
ganz präzise im parlamentarischen
verfahren festlegen kann gehört auch
dazu aber wichtig ist dass die entschied
primären die wichtigsten entscheidungen
auch vom parlament schon mit der
schaffung des sondervermögens oder
möglicherweise auch im weiteren verlauf
geschaffen werden und wenn man das mit
zwei-drittel-mehrheit im grundgesetz
verankert dann ist das natürlich auch
ein festes fundament das nicht zum
beispiel mit einfacher mehrheit dann
irgendwelche mittel wieder in neue
kanäle fließen können von daher ist das
schon aus verfassungsrechtlicher sicht
auch nachvollziehbar dass man
offensichtlich diesen weg wählt und
was die besonderheit der schuldenbremse
angeht also jetzt hier der artikel 115
da denke ich mal dass das sondervermögen
wurde auf der sicheren seite sein wird
weil in den planungen die im moment
bekannt sind ja extra eine durchbrechung
der schuldenbremse für dieses
sondervermögen der bundeswehr vorgesehen
ist und wenn das mit zweidrittelmehrheit
verfassungsrechtlich so beschlossen wird
dann im so jedenfalls mein mann
gegenwärtiger zugang dürfte das auch
eine eine verfassungsrechtlich sichere
durchbrechung der schuldenbremse
darstellen genau diese durchbrechung die
soll ja eingefügt werden in den artikel
87a grundgesetz und da ist im
referentenentwurf jetzt die rede davon
diese mittel sollten der bündnis und
verteidigungsfähigkeit
dienen ist das hinreichend präzise dass
man dann weiß wofür das geld jetzt
eigentlich ausgegeben werden darf und
wofür nicht
das sondervermögen für die bundeswehr
wird nach dem kenntnisstand in ich habe
ja nicht allein eine
verfassungsrechtliche verankerung haben
also in der tat wird die wesentliche
grundlage in dem artikel 87a des
grundgesetzes
stattfinden das ist sicherlich auch ein
anknüpfungspunkt der sich anbietet wenn
man sich die konstruktion des
grundgesetzes anschaut aber es wird ja
noch eine reihe weiterer
detailregelungen dieses sondervermögens
bedürfen die auch mit parlamentsmehrheit
vermutlich auch dann mit einer zwei
drittel mehrheit beschlossen werden das
weiß ich nicht aber ich denke dass es
jedenfalls politisch eher sinnvoll sein
dürfte dass dann alles gemeinsam auch
mit einer zweidrittelmehrheit
vereinbart wird und ich denke in diesem
weiteren gesetzgebungsverfahren wird man
die begrifflichkeiten die
mittelverwendung doch noch wesentlich
präziser festlegen und auch festlegen
müssen denn die anbindung an das
parlament muss eine sehr enge und sehr
feste seien man im corona sondervermögen
in hessen war es eben ein problem das zu
einem wesentlichen teil seitens der
exekutive dann entschieden wurde wofür
die mittel eingesetzt werden bis zu
einer million euro waren die maßnahmen
ganz ohne beteiligung des parlaments
möglich ab einer million euro gab es
eine anbindung an den haushaltsausschuss
da haben wir allerdings in unserer
entscheidung auch hervorgehoben dass die
anbindung an den haushaltsausschuss
nicht die beteiligung des gesamten
parlamentes ersetzt denn im
haushaltsausschuss sind nur einzelne
abgeordnete beispielsweise auch nicht
fraktionslose abgeordnete aber auch nur
ein ausschnitt des parlamentes vertreten
und das reicht eben nicht um die gesamt
anbindung an das parlament zu
gewährleisten ja dann würde ich sagen
gibt es da quasi ein paar leitplanken
wie die politik jetzt auch
berücksichtigen muss bei der
ausgestaltung dieses
sondervermögens für die bundeswehr auch
ein paar beispiele aus hessen wo sie
sich orientieren kann ja vielen dank an
roman postech präsident des hessischen
staatsgerichtshofs und des
oberlandesgerichts in frankfurt das
waren ein paar ja ich sag mal hessische
erfahrung und hessische eindrücke zu
diesen beiden fragen die uns beim thema
sondervermögen gerade beschäftigen
einmal nachtragshaushalt für den
klimaschutz und einmal sondervermögen
für die bundeswehr vielen dank gerne
herr professor die fabio erleben wir
gerade eine krise der freiheit eine
krise der freiheit ich würde sagen herr
müller behandelt sich gerade um einen
vorgang den ich als selbstbehauptung der
freiheit bezeichnet wurde in der ukraine
kämpft ein volk um seine freiheit und
wir die westlichen demokratien
unterstützen dieses sollte vielleicht
für nicht militärisch war das nicht zu
verantworten wäre aber unterhalb der
schwelle des direkten eingreifen
doch sehr stark ja die freiheit wie ist
bedrängt
da von außen vielleicht auch tendenzen
aber
wie befindet sich doch in einem prozess
der verteidigung der selbstbehauptung
und ich bin auch zuversichtlich dass das
gelingt stichwort indira tendenzen gilt
das auch für die pandemie ja eine
weitere krise die uns schon länger
beschäftigt selbstbehauptung der
freiheit ist sie da auf dem vormarsch
oder eher auf dem rückzug
also auch hier wäre ich nicht so
pessimistisch wie manche
kommentatoren dass auch ein bisschen die
rechtswissenschaft gesehen haben die
pandemie war natürlich ein
außergewöhnliches ereignis hat uns
grundrechtseingriffe beschert die wir so
flächendeckend nicht für möglich
gehalten hätten zuvor
aber und wenn man im internationalen
vergleich fraud dann sind doch
diejenigen die behauptete haben das uns
autokratien und diktaturen bei der
bekämpfung und eindämmung der korona
pandemie überlegen sind die sind doch
still geworden
man sieht dass der westen natürlich
interaktiv lernen hier vorgegangen ist
film manchmal
mit der springprozession
paar schritte vor paar schritte zurück
aber
aber letztlich glaube ich dass wir im
vergleich zu china besser dastehen wir
haben diese krise die ist ja noch nicht
zu ende
wir werden uns noch glaube ich auch
einige
gefahren hier
einstellen müssen aber insgesamt hat
sich auch hier unsere gesellschaft
bewährt wir haben viel geld ausgegeben
wir haben die freiheit beschränkt aber
doch immer so dass das auch dass die
freiheit auch dann zurückgegeben wurde
wenn das vertretbar wenn es
verantwortbar war wir haben nicht über
ein notstand regime
jetzt unsere grundstrukturen angelastet
ist das trotzdem zugleich eine
verfassungskrise in der das
freiheitsverständnis sich etwas
verschoben hat gerade auch mit blick auf
die öffnungen die jetzt ja in kraft
treten sollen auch widerstand erregen
die frage was war zuerst oder ist zuerst
die beschränkung ist zuerst die freiheit
wie ist es mit freiheit und
verantwortung hat sich da etwas
begrifflich auch verschoben
also ich glaube wir können in den
letzten zwei jahrzehnten ungefähr seit
ausbruch der weltfinanzkrise können wir
beobachten
dass ein stärkeres vertrauen und ein
stärkeres misstrauen in den markt aber
auch überhaupt in die bewegungsgesetze
der freien gesellschaft breit macht ein
stück weit ist der pendelschlag vom
neoliberalismus zu einer art geo
dirigismus wie das
wirtschaftswissenschaftler sagen
erfolgt durch die korona pandemie ist
bei vielen menschen das vertrauen in den
staat
vor allen dingen wenn er recht
erfolgreich die pandemie gemanagt hat
wie das etwa in deutschland der fall war
gestiegen und gestiegene staat vertrauen
ist per se nichts schlechtes aber
wenn es ein zu starkes vertrauen wird
und wenn darunter das vertrauen in die
in die selbstentfaltung kräfte der
gesellschaft schwindet dann wäre das für
eine liberale demokratie
bedenklich ob das jetzt der fall ist das
weiß ich nicht wie beobachten ja auch
dass die gesellschaft
fragmentiert ist ein ganzes stück weit
die einen waren die maßnahmen und finden
sie bis heute unverhältnismäßig und
überzogen
und andere
wollen in die normalität noch nicht
zurück und bei manchen hat man den
eindruck sie wollen nie mehr in die
normalität zurück ja ist das wenn man
vom individuellen grundrecht auch ein
institutionelles problem stichwort bund
länder wer darf was muss hier jetzt
vielleicht auch über die pandemie hinaus
aber aus anlass der partie nie etwas neu
justiert für einem verfassungsgefüge
also wir sind ein bundesstaates müssen
wir auch qua verfassung bleiben aber hat
sich das so bewährt
wurden länder gemeinden bei der
bestrafung solcher krisen ja also wir
haben ja hier beim bundes
infektionsschutzgesetz die
gesetzgebungskompetenz beim bund aber
die verwaltungskompetenz sie dass der
regel des grundgesetzes entspricht bei
den ländern das ist das hat zutaten zum
teil zu irritationen geführt im verlauf
der pandemie
ist aber ein stück weit
ich hatte es gesagt
verfassungsrechtlicher normalfall der
föderalismus in deutschland
haben wir staatliche erfahrung
eigentlich nur im föderalismus mit
ausnahme der beiden diktaturen die wir
auf deutschem boden erlebt haben und
trotzdem wundert man sich wie wenig
föderal eigentlich unser politisches
bewusstsein ist ein journalist der
flickenteppich schreibt der hat in der
krise immer großen große akzeptanz ein
politiker ist recht ja und der politiker
natürlich kann man bekommt applaus
solche diagnosen und wenn ich durchs
land ziehen würde und den für realismus
kritisieren würde also gehen und als
teuer als
nicht effizient glaube ich dann hätte
ich mal große zustimmung allein es
spricht entspricht nicht den tatsachen
der verwaltungs hat eben auch viele
vorzüge und wie alles was vor zugehört
hat er auch nachteile natürlich
aber ich glaube dass ein zentralstaat
wie frankreich insgesamt keineswegs
besser regiert wird und auch nicht
effizienter regiert wird
interessanterweise weil der aufwand für
den öffentlichen dienst in frankreich
eher höher ist als in deutschland
obwohl wir uns neben der bundesregierung
noch 16 landesregierungen erlauben also
ich würde hier nicht allgemein für den
föderalismus werben aber die ständige
forderungen bei disparitäten im zuge
einer krisenbewältigung die dann im
föderalismus angelastet werden und dann
zum ruf nach verfassungsänderungen
führen das hat uns in den letzten 20
jahren in im verfassungsrecht in den
bund länder beziehung nicht wesentlich
weiter gebracht das grundgesetz ist
mehrfach geändert worden und nicht immer
zum guten
deshalb bin ich da skeptisch und würde
eher sagen
und lasst uns doch lernen mit dem
föderalismus zu leben dann ersparen wir
uns jedenfalls solche
manchmal aufgeregten strukturdebatten
eine weitere debatte steht uns ja bevor
er hat schon angefangen zu einer neuen
verfassungsänderung da geht es um die
schuldenbremse beziehungsweise um ihre
ergänzung im zuge dieser krisen ist ja
auch deutlich geworden dass manche
preisstruktur und veraltet waren aber
auch das geld fehlt dass man offenbar im
normalen haushalts gefüge nicht mehr
platzieren kann wie sehen sie dass die
schuldenbremse über diese weise auch
selbst noch am verfassungsgericht
befunden haben war ja schon immer da
wurde dann als im grunde loses papier
wert angesehen weil sie dauernd
gebrochen wurde wurde dann verschärft
und jetzt leben wir erleben wir krisen
die es offensichtlich erfordern sie
verfassungsrechtlich zu ergänzen was ihr
verfassungsrechtlich dann kein problem
ist oder eben sondervermögen zu schaffen
wird hier auch etwas ausgehebelt das zum
kernbestand der verfassung gehört herr
müller ist eine wirklich schwierige
frage die schuldenbremse
in der tat ja nicht erst bei der
verschärfung gegeben seitdem wir stärker
auch eine öffentlichkeit auf sich
schauen sondern auch woher und ich hätte
mir als verfassungsrichter ja das
zusammen mit einem kollegen ein
sondervotum niedergelegt
eine schärfere handhabung von der alten
schuldenbremse gewünscht als sie dann
verschärft wurde war ich aber keineswegs
beruhigt oder durch er weilt jeder der
die in versuch geschlechts ob das jetzt
das europäische unions rechte ist mit
seinen stabilitätskriterien oder
schuldenbremsen auf bundes- oder auch
länder ebene sich anschaut sieht wenn
man den politischen prozess wirksam mit
recht bei einnahmen und ausgaben binden
will dann fängt man hier ein raubtier
und
man ahnt dass die haupt hier an den
ketten rütteln sie äpfel und auch die
kraft hat solche ketten irgendwann
abzustreifen also die
diese ständige spannung im
verfassungsstaat zwischen recht und
politischer macht sie wird wenn man nur
wenn man wirklich haushaltsdisziplin mit
dem recht einfordert die zu einer
konfrontativen frage und die politik
überlegt deshalb ja auch die
stabilitätskriterien auf der
europäischen ebene
ich sage jetzt mal aufzuweichen also die
fesseln zu lockern und auf der
bundesebene überlegen wir das auch und
die länder die ja noch stärker gefesselt
sind als der bund die sehen das nur
deshalb etwas entspannter weil in den
letzten jahren der bund sehr stark
eigentlich hier eingesprungen ist aber
inzwischen
auch an grenzen seiner eigenen
leistungsfähigkeit stößt also
ist jetzt die frage
wird die schuldenbremse artikel 115 des
grundgesetzes wird der modifiziert wird
er verändert
oder gehen wir in einem prozess der der
perpetuiert
notstandssituation wo wir ein kia die
notstands klausel betätigen allerdings
dann doch sehr unübersichtlichen und
langzeit wirkenden tilgungsplan kommen
müssten also das wird auch keine lösung
sein und jetzt ist plötzlich der
scheinbar elegante vorschlag des
sondervermögens da sondervermögen sind
jetzt keine erfindung unserer seite wir
kennen ja solche sondervermögen aus der
vergangenheit der fonds deutsche einheit
beispielsweise war ein solches
sondervermögen sondervermögen bedeutet
eine in einem nebenhaushalt neben dem
haushaltsplan neben dem regulären
haushaltsplan artikel 110 das
grundgesetz erlaubt so etwas obwohl
damit der grundsatz dass der
haushaltsplan des bundes vollständig
sein muss
ein stück weit
gelockert hat jetzt die neuheit damit
das sondervermögen gar nicht erst
verfassungsrechtlich angreifbar wird
mit einer verfassungsänderung das
sondervermögen der bundeswehr zu
etablieren ja das wird wohl nicht gegen
die ewigkeitsgarantie verstoßen und wird
deshalb das bundesverfassungsgericht
auch binden
ihn bei seiner interpretation aber man
sieht es jedenfalls verfassungspolitisch
nicht ohne sorgen wenn dieses beispiel
schule machen sollte könnte das beste
system aus
dann werden wir bald eine reihe und
nebenhaushalten haben und keiner kann
mehr genau über schauen wie hoch ist
eigentlich die schulden gleich der
bundesrepublik deutschland wirklich und
dass diese gefahr sehen sie real obwohl
man ja dafür eine zweidrittelmehrheit
braucht die jetzt zustande kommt
offensichtlich dass man sozusagen das
ergänzt das führt zu der frage inwieweit
formal verfassungsgemäß ist es dann
natürlich gemacht aber man schafft
ausnahmen diese zeugen dieses
grundprinzip infragestellen von band von
zeitenwende gesprochen wird so ist es ja
so dass auch die ampel schon vor der
aktuellen krise einige
grundgesetzänderung angepeilt hat
stichwort rasse aus dem grundgesetz war
weiter senken ist da etwas dabei dass
sie auch unbedingt erforderlich halten
wenn sie einen wunsch frei hätten wo
muss das grundgesetz geändert werden
im jahr
die frage ist schon mal gestellt worden
als das grundgesetz 70 wurde
da habe ich das aber nicht gedruckt
sehen wollen und deshalb weiß ich auch
gar nicht ob ich das jetzt
auf akustischen wege hinterher geben
soll aber man könnte vielleicht die
ursprungsfassung des grundgesetzes 49
wiederherstellen das ist natürlich nur
ironisch gemeint aber der tendenz nicht
die rote schnitten in der tendenz
gibt es ein paar grundgesetzänderungen
die man
die man für günstig halten kann zum
beispiel die reduktion der zahl der
zustimmungspflichtigen gesetze hat
letztlich und die entflechtung die damit
zusammenhängen hat letztlich den
föderalismus ein stückweit genutzt und
das wäre also ich kann deshalb nicht
sagen dass alle änderung des
grundgesetzes irgendwie
negativ zu bewerten wären das will ich
bestimmt nicht sagen aber es gibt eine
reihe von änderungen des grundgesetzes
wo sich das grundgesetz dann allmählich
liebste wie eine sammlung und
verwaltungsvorschriften und es wird den
verfassungstext nicht gerecht die teil
der föderalismusreform
sind ja dann auch wieder rückgängig
gemacht worden man hat den goldenen
zügel erst abgeschafft und jetzt wird er
punktuell wieder eingeführt das tut
einem verfassungs korpus nicht gut und
auch der akzeptanz des grundgesetzes
nicht gut wenn man das wahlalter ändern
will und den wertungswiderspruch
hinnehmen will dass ein 16-jähriger eine
16-jährige war keinen handyvertrag
abschließen darf aber die regierung der
bundesrepublik deutschland bestimmen
darf und man darin keinen
beklemmenden wertungswiderspruch sieht
bitteschön wir hatten eine solche
konstellation auch von den siebziger
jahren als man noch mit 21 volljährig
wurde und auch mittags schon wählen
konnte wie weit man dieses spiel nach
unten verlegen ich weiß nicht ein stück
weit müssen wir vielleicht auch einmal
die ernsthaftigkeit von demokratie und
die bedeutung der wahlentscheidung
wieder ins rechte licht rücken es ist
wichtiger dass jemand entscheiden kann
wer die bundesrepublik regiert als ob er
in die privatinsolvenz gerät deshalb
wer wer will das mit 16 gewählt wird das
soll doch auch die volljährigkeit und
auch die strafmündigkeit mit sechzehn
geben und räder sagt gottes willen das
geht doch gar nicht er muss sich auch
mal als demokrat fragen lassen welche
wertschätzung genießt eigentlich die
demokratie im vergleich zur
privatautonomie des bürgers also zu
sehen auch das sind wieder änderungen
des grundgesetzes
in die man durchaus verfassungspolitisch
kritisch gesehen kann das heißt auch
nicht bis zur verfassungsfrage erklären
was ja auch wiederum zu mehr verfangen
karlsruhe führt ein halt nur kannst du
tabuisierung unter umständen ja nicht
nur wegen karls roman wird jetzt auch an
dem beispiel sondervermögen des bundes
hier regiert jetzt plötzlich die
opposition in dem augenblick mit wo sie
ihre zustimmung geben muss und man sieht
wie die union als opposition im bund
darum ringt an welche konditionen wie
das eigentlich binden soll die kondition
die regierungstragende mehrheit
einheitlich abstimmen soll ist nett aber
im grunde genommen müsste eine
opposition wenn sie einen scheck für 100
milliarden bundeswehr erteilt doch auch
über die verwendung der mittel in
anderer weise mit reden müssen als das
parlamentarisch ohnehin
vorgeschrieben und werks haben ist das
heißt sie müsste ein stück weit mit
regieren und das sollte den weg über
sondervermögen die in der verfassung
verankert werden vielleicht ein wenig
jedoch mit vorsicht
genießen lassen wenn man aber dieser
ansicht folgte ja auch die ampel
vertritt das gesellschaftlicher wandel
sich auch in der verfassung spiegeln
muss also wahlalter meinetwegen auch der
rasse begriff müsste man nicht dann auch
man muss auch die ehe anpassen weil die
verfassungsväter und mütter von einem
anderen ehrbegriff ausgegangen sind
würde man muss nicht immer die
verfassung anpassen wir haben ja noch
eine interpretation instanz in karlsruhe
das ist doch die gegen verfassungsfeinde
sozusagen im rahmen der interpretation
erlebt ja das tut das
bundesverfassungsgericht doch auch
in einer in einer ich würde sagen
überwiegend sehr besonnen weise aber
dass wir jetzt im klima beschluss
praktisch ein grundrecht auf
nachhaltigen klimaschutz für entwickelt
haben das hätte man sich hätte
sicherlich der verfassungsändernden
gesetzgeber da hinein schreiben können
als artikel 20a formuliert wurde hat er
das ersichtlich so sich nicht gedacht
und hier hat das
bundesverfassungsgericht also den
verfassungs wandel bis an die grenzen
der auslegungsmöglichkeiten aber nicht
über sie hinaus dann nachgezogen also es
muss nicht immer der
verfassungsändernden gesetzgeber fallen
wir kennen ja alte demokratien die wie
im vereinigten königreich ohne
geschriebene verfassung weitgehend
auskommen oder wien in usa die ihr
ursprungs dokument praktisch gar nicht
antasten
klar gibts management aber dass da jeder
jede neue gesellschaftspolitische idee
auch gleich zu einer verfassungsänderung
im text verhört wird auch dort nicht
erwartet also ich glaube manchmal ist
das eine symbolpolitik die von den
politischen akteuren in seiner wirkung
in ihrer wirkung nicht immer
ganz rational berechnet wird aber das
ist schon fast eine verfassungs
theoretische frage die wir hier du bist
wie kreativ wollen ist aber häufig
verboten sie hatten das vereinte
königreich angesprochen das hat ja
seinen austritt aus der europäischen
union erklärt im koalitionsvertrag steht
im aktuellen
noch gültigen sozusagen jedenfalls
schriftlich die dort drin man strebe
auch eine einer europäischen bundesstaat
an
wie sehen sie die chancen auch
angesichts der gerade angesprochenen
selbstbehauptung der freiheit ist es
auch eine selbstbehauptung der nationen
oder geht die tendenz eher in die andere
richtung ja das ist er in der deutschen
politik einen schon vielfach formuliert
vielen europäischen bundesstaat
anzusteuern vorher noch eine europäische
armee wird gelegentlich auch gesagt ja
nur muss man da ein paar sachen glaube
ich immer vorenthalten
die annahme dass
die französische republik einen
europäischen bundesstaat wolle ist ein
missverständnis wenn
man frankreich fragen würde ob sie auch
die eigene horst rapp und ob sie vor
allen dingen auf den sitz den ständigen
sitz im un-sicherheitsrat verpflichten
wollen
weil sie ja nur noch teilstaat in einem
europäischen bundesstaat wäre es sie
würden keine sie haben keine chance eine
volksabstimmung in frankreich zu
gewinnen also deshalb kann man das von
deutschland aus wo ich fordern ohne
gefahr zu laufen dass er tatsächlich
kommt der der und staat in einem echten
staatsrechtlich substanziellen sinne
deshalb stehen wir vor der frage wie
sieht denn auch der grundlage des
staatenbundes eigentlich die möglichkeit
aus die selbstbehauptung europas
effektiver zu machen und das muss nicht
die europäische armee sein das wäre
schon unglaublich viel erreicht wenn wir
als starkes standbein der nato und
innerhalb europas noch stärker ich würde
mal sagen deutlich stärker integrieren
würden integrieren im nato verbund heißt
ja gar nicht dass man nicht souveränität
über seine armee verliert sondern nur
dass man etwa mit gemeinsamer
beschaffung mit gemeinsamen verbänden
die auch wirklich koordiniert operieren
könnten unterwegs ist und da haben wir
viel zu wenig getan und da haben wir ein
riesiges politisches hält so was hat mit
verfassungsänderungen nicht tun dass
baumann auch keine europäische verträge
für zu ändern sondern muss man machen
und dabei muss man auch die interessen
aus parieren
promovieren denn rüstungsprojekt in
auftrag gegeben wer zahlt denn dafür wie
viel hat man dafür 100 milliarden für
die bundeswehr das ist nur im grunde
genommen ein tropfen auf den heißen
stein obwohl der betrag gewaltig klingt
wir haben in deutschland jetzt 20 jahre
lang die friedensdividende eingestrichen
in dem wir nicht nachhaltig in
verteidigung investiert haben die
deutsche die deutsche politik sollte
weniger vom bundesstaat reden sondern
sollte endlich anfangen in die
europäische verteidigung wirksam zu
investieren vielen dank das war ein
gutes schlusswort
geradezu herzlich nach ach ja
das war unser faz einspruch podcast
spezial zum thema krieg verschuldung
zeitenwende was wird aus dem grundgesetz
es war ein etwas länger aber umso
reichere sendung mit drei hochkarätigen
gesprächspartnern in der kommenden woche
gibt es wieder die reguläre folge des
einspruchs podcasts wir bedanken uns
fürs zuhören und freuen uns wie immer
auf ihre anregung und themenvorschläge
am besten unter einspruch podcast in
einem wort faz.de wir wünschen ihnen ein
schönes wochenende liebe hörer auch von
mir eine schöne zeit und bleiben sie
einspruch treu
[Musik]